remettez comme outil pour faire alors
j'ai pas grand chose un petit pain de
campagne en moyenne il ya plus gros
voilà comme coupée en deux mais voilà là
pour l'argent lui c'est ce qu'il faut
après là dessus j'y mets quelques
petites feuilles de salade
de gésiers de la mairie magret et du
foie gras chaud et ont refermé le
couvercle et en mange alors vous avez
décidé que cette année
le palais grave parce que c'est bon
maintenant est un petit la a et un
joueur à l'âge légal a reçu encore foie
gras voilà on va dire que ce soit a
nourri sa non et ça c'est pas mauvais
c'est bon maintenant vous savez je vous
ai apporté suite bordeaux comme ça vous
avez sur sainte vierge marie
bourgueil classique traditionnelle le
modèle du genre de riez pas tranquille
c'est un joueur de qualité de riom des
lampes en te permets réponse